had a doctor like this about four years
ago he goes huh some of the new blood
south looks good um uni m'q oh my go
no and he goes I go what news no nothing
just something a little low but I think
it's gonna be okay
Firebird seems good know one thing he's
feeling my neck he goes he goes on a
checkup I know my back told me this mmm
I was a little bit bigger than normal
maybe I don't think it's cancer or
anything so don't worry
I go [ __ ] dude what are you talking
one up yet so I got a thing is -
fighting Gabriel Gonzaga in Anaheim the
California it might is either California
Jersey their Commission's are super
strict so you have to get more than just
blood work something you just have to
blood work you get do a full MRI cat
scan your brain everything they check
everything
a man had to go get like an MRI and a
cat scan on my brain the doctor comes in
you know they had the papers and he's
flipping through us yeah you see
everything's all good
oh we did find a tumor in the base of
your brain when I know but I'd keep an
eye on it and then let's see here you're
also I'm like oh my god he goes yeah
we said you saw tumor it was did see a
little tumor to whack your brain but
it's benign so it's probably gonna grow
you probably have that since you were
kid nothing to be alarmed about but I
would keep an eye on it and what I'll do
that how do i I am my love users and
then other than that you should be all
set to fight in the steel cage and I'm a
star crying why you got my cart why go
oh my god with my in DUIs I'll just take
fish oil yeah a baby tumor it didn't
hear your pituitary maybe that's why
you're such a giant no I'm not like
Bigfoot Silva sits in the back here Oh a
little baby to me they said if it did
flare up I would have issues yeah they
can't remove it though
game over cuz you'll dyers that the
Anthony said so that's why sometimes you
go I don't think that very long as I say
that yeah yeah no my family knows they
didn't know before
what's home boy has a tumor I'll pay you
you're not for tumor
it's benign no baby it's all gravy I
knew that do you tell me that a long
time ago I've never sold anybody it's
out there in the ether I've never told
anybody ever that yeah they say it
pushes on the clan that makes your dick
huge what it is super good karma tumor
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift